[Music]
in Nick represent News Nick died now you
represent that's what it says submitted
by Tariq from southeast London London
London [ __ ] Yanks two guys made a
fake McDonald's ad and hung it in the
restaurant where it stayed for almost
two months I saw this I was like dude
that's [ __ ] genius yeah thank you
show me this one have you guys even know
these Asian guys right yeah these two
Asian gates are they're from the
University of Houston
Cooperstown yeah each town hey stop it
yeah and then so they're saying that
they notice that their local McDonald's
that there was not a single asian person
in any of the ads that were hung up all
over the restaurant and so he was like
he they saw a blank wall and they
decided to post this up they created
this they photoshopped these fries in
and make them look perfect that's dull
you've made a YouTube video about it
that's awesome
so then they they took it down after two
months so my knowledge is still up so
baby they waited like til it was like 52
days or some [ __ ] and then they they
posted about it on the plan yeah because
this tweet it says one of the guys he
tweeted a he said I noticed there was a
blink long McDonald so I decided to make
this fake poster of me and my friend
it's now been 51 days since I hung it up
I love it so did I love it I love
harmless like yeah pranks well do not
pranks but like so little it's a little
protest it's like an art used to yeah
yeah yeah I like it it's like some
Banksy [ __ ] yeah but the coolest [ __ ]
[ __ ] about it is so these guys I guess
they printed they got it like an old
McDonald's like employee shirt old shirt
and then they printed up some [ __ ]
[ __ ] badge that says like McDonald's
interior decorator thing yeah and they
just walked in and hung it up
undercover elaborate is [ __ ] yeah look
he had the shirt on just in case anyone
questioning but honestly like no one
even batted an eye cuz they waited for
the perfect opportunity when there was
no employees around and then they had
like the sticky tape on on the poster
and then his two friends helped them so
like they were level that's usually how
corporate is though like you just have
people come in and out and just change
all the ads and stuff and no one has to
check in with anyone you just assume
that's like what happens and it's
McDonald's I'm sure they've seen crazier
[ __ ] than yeah as long as it's not a
homeless guy vomiting on the floor I
think you know two guys putting a
picture up and they see the picture that
looks legit yeah that's what's so good
about it that looks so legit but you
could look like [ __ ] it wouldn't be as
funny that's amazed that looks so good I
like how they're enjoying their
McDonald's right there - yeah it's just
having his friend that's great they
should have done the same exact pose but
I think um McDonald's is pretty good on
the whole like diversity theme because
when you know you're in a Mexican
neighborhood or a white neighborhood or
whatever depending on what kind of
pictures are in McDonald's - like a lot
of our McDonald's over here does have
like Chinese Asian and it's like even on
the billboards you'll see like a Chinese
family it's not even in English it's got
like Chinese writing and [ __ ] and it's
usually like the dad lecturing a son
yeah but they really misrepresent are
they under represent the morbidly obese
which I think that's the reason I really
believe I'll say this man a million
times they really need proper
representation I want to hang up all the
real customers of McDonald's like you
got like a straight up tourist immigrant
family that just came here yesterday you
have like a homeless dude that uses it
as his nap time
you have like the seniors that [ __ ]
go there to socialize in the morning you
know you got like the you got the dude
that that's like his wife is gone and he
doesn't know how to cook so he's like
stare with his kids and [ __ ] you got
like you know the guy is [ __ ] boxers
and sandals like with a like an open
robe and he's like there
[ __ ] love the all this [ __ ] exactly
that's the real McDonald's dude real
customers of McDonald the people of
wal-mart and the people of McDonald's
are the same people I think dollars will
go worse sometimes sometimes but that's
also why McDonald and Walmart it's sort
of convenient there you go it's exactly
right
but you never see those people it's
always like unoffensive facial hair on
the ads like [ __ ] unbelievable they
should stop denying their customers like
they need to celebrate and recognize
they don't know that it's because they
all in corporate have the idea of their
dream customer their perfect customer
that's all these like like model perfect
like black ladies model perfect white
dude like everyone's got model features
no they're smart because no one wants to
identify themselves as a piece of trash
so when they're in McDonald's and they
look at that guy with the unoffensive
facial hair they're like I'm him we're
the same but it's also inaccurate Mario
farts and you're the wet splash but
don't you think homeless people look at
these pictures and say that is not a
fair representation of me just like
these Asian guys came in he was like hey
where's all the Asians at yeah and all
the homeless people are like yo man we
[ __ ] we are the main customer base of
this [ __ ]
make sure have a picture on the wall of
McDonald's person reaching out and look
for the driver and then the driver is
like yelling at them because they free
awesome [ __ ] that's an accurate
representation of what person going like
this in the drive-through and then the
other person going like this cuz the
[ __ ] soft-serve machine is always
broken yeah
liar cleaning the machines yeah yeah
right pal yup we need like a angry Becky
with her three kids and she's yelling at
the manager we need some real accurate
pictures of the life of McDonald's man
this will be awesome I would love that
[ __ ] they could be real with their
customer base I have an idea that I want
to do the video idea because I've been
thinking what do what I do to come back
on you here right I was thinking I just
interview people as they come out of a
Hometown Buffet
oh that's it that was my favorite place
in the world I work through another
customer to me there is no lower moment
that I could think of walking out of the
home type of thing why it's one of the
happiest moments have affordable yes
video it's pretty nuts
no it'll be pretty good imagine people
coming out it's like hey man how's it
going man I was like man they
collaborated with sin of Cinnabon and
they have cinnamon twists there yeah
really and they got better they got
better I mean it's still alive today
it's still hometown look let me upgrade
to a soup plantation that you know seems
like sided side dude it's like hometown
phase way lower back in it Oh things
better now yeah it is no job what's
wrong with me that I never thought it
was beneath the Hometown Buffet I
thought it was pretty elevated back in
the day I thought it was nice and talked
about like 10 you got all those Norman
Rockwell painting or whatever I've never
seen a happy person in a Hometown Buffet
you should have saw me you should have
saw me but you don't cares only
devastated looking families even the
employee you know one time I went to
work and I was just because I gotta find
boyfriend yeah and I was just so like so
sad and then there was this one you're
doing buffet I work there
oh I went to work and then
the customers came in and I think yells
they scolded me luckily if you don't
like your job then why are you working
here and I was like because in reality
it had to go I have to go home
gonna do it but yeah home tell my baby's
not happy right it's just people who
look like they just got bad dude dude my
memories were always great at Hometown
Buffet you were a kid though being a kid
you're oblivious to a lot of things that
are happening I didn't see all the sad
faces on your parents you didn't see the
sad criticism and I thought that word
genius cuz before when I was a kid the
first thing I would always think about
is how can I like scheisse this place
yeah and then sauce oh [ __ ] if it's a
buffet I could open the back door people
come in but then when you go in with
their party they immediately got all a
party of five and they write that number
on the hint so I was like out when I
walked into a place I was already like
trying to sculpt it out like I was like
Ocean's eleven even though I was only
eight we heisted that food but then as
soon as I found out I was like [ __ ] okay
cross that plan out I can't do that plan
it'll make guys pretty smart yeah you
know what I used to work there people
used to ask me for doggy bags like oh
can I take this to go and I'm like this
is a they do that now and then I found
out that they do that well cuz people
kept doing it I mean like I would go
with my so I'll be like with my Filipino
friends and their mom would have [ __ ]
big-ass plastic bags in their purse and
they would put food in later that's its
home down but I thought that was so cool
though because we would have cookies and
[ __ ] later smart but I don't know now
I'm looking back I'm like that is pretty
[ __ ] loaded but I thought they were
the coolest they were the coolest
[ __ ] family matter because my mom
would never do that [ __ ] no I don't see
what it's like there's what I hear
Montebello let's go let's do it I'm
interviewing every one of you afterwards
soft-serve [ __ ] baked goods mac and
cheese oh my god I don't know if their
color you just describing desserts let's
talk the main course okay good the mac
and cheese is bad pizza when you really
got it I don't know dude Carnival Cruise
at the taco bar that's pretty good yeah
that's pretty good
you make your own tacos machines shrimp
scampi underneath assignment what's the
difference between Hometown Buffet and a
circus circus buffet or like the Luxan
there we don't do this circus pervert
how many times have we been to Vegas
together and we someone was like oh I
know where to eat I've been there but
you guys have it would you say out loud
while we're all in Vegas let's go to the
circuit circus buffet where you go there
to play craps in this way they were
losing welcome $9.99 all-you-can-eat
you've never once mentioned it what well
cuz and we were at the circus circus
yeah we were I have money now
what do you mean here with us I'd like a
couple months ago no no no but then like
my memories of it is when I'm like 20
years old and I'm in Vegas and I can't
do much so then it was time ten dollars
so now you're where I'm talking about
which is the Hometown Buffet sadness the
general merit the lack of married but I
was mad I was appreciative though I was
never sad I think if I'm 50 years old
then that would be sad that's [ __ ]
[Music]